it is fertility answers live with Alice
preachy co-founder and CEO of the
fertility app and my dear friend and
colleague dr. Serena each Chen who's
finally back so happy that you're back I
hope that you enjoyed your time off we
have a lot to cover today yes
so today's Monday motivation is a tough
topic because we need to address
coronavirus as it relates to fertility
and we don't have a lot of answers so I
think today's topic is going to be of
motivating people to have the right
conversation with their provider but we
know some things yeah is that we know
that coronavirus is very unlikely to
live in eggs or sperm so that's good
news that's great
I also think that you know if you've
been to a high-risk area you're and you
don't get sick you're cleared within 14
days which is also really good so that's
different from Zika virus which is if
you've traveled to a Zika virus area you
can take 2 to 3 months before you're
cleared even if you rather have symptoms
I also think it's important to look at
the relative scale of things so that the
flu is apparently already responsible
this year in the United States for
thousands and thousands of deaths and
really coronavirus it the numbers for
coronavirus are very small compared to
the flu and the flu we have a vaccine
which we would really like everybody
trying to conceive or pregnant or
everybody to get the flu vaccine because
you can dramatically reduce the risk to
yourself to your children to your family
to everybody by getting the vaccine it's
not perfect but it really helps to
reduce the influence and the death rate
and we worry about the flu a lot because
pregnant people are one of the
vulnerable populations that can die from
the flu pregnant people don't appear to
be more
more susceptible to death from the
coronavirus so I think that's also
positive I agree with that you know we
don't know for sure but it appears that
pregnant people are not necessarily more
vulnerable to the corona virus it seems
like if you're healthy and you're
pregnant you kind of have are the same
as everybody else so let's step back for
a quick minute and let's let's actually
remember what it was like when Zika hit
and when stars hit because there are
similarities this isn't going to be the
last virus that is that's true that this
happens where it's scary there's a lot
of misinformation people might be
blowing it out of proportion you know we
haven't we haven't necessarily ever seen
maybe the the length of time people are
being quarantined for in whole cities
and I certainly don't remember with Zika
travel being shut down like this but I
might be remembering wrong so let's
let's back up for a second remember Zika
because Zika was really devastating to
people who were pregnant because we had
an end a birth defect that was caused by
that virus and it was correct me if I'm
wrong mosquito-borne virus right right
born and sexually transmitted now we
didn't have travel shut down with Zika
because people weren't really because it
was sexual transmission and
mosquito-borne transmission and the big
risk was birth defects
it wasn't like we're gonna have like a
public health epidemic if a lot of
people got Zika they would get a little
bit sick and the red would be done
finally it was really more about for
Reproductive people and reproduction
worried about like having a baby that
could have birth defects so what
happened to Zika so Zika the Zika
outbreak the epidemic seems to be under
good control but the risk for getting
Zika if you travel to high-risk areas is
still potentially there so we
still like people who are trying to
conceive and pregnant to avoid travel to
the Caribbean Central America sent South
America Southeast Asia and Central
Africa and you connect on the CDC
website to look at the map and see you
know one of the areas you shouldn't
travel to now the CDC map is a little
bit confusing right now because you're
supposed to avoid travel to the purple
areas except for the continental United
States and France are purple those are
not travel advisories those are mosquito
advisory ah gotcha okay purple areas and
the rest of the world outside
continental universities and France our
travel advisories and if you can travel
to those areas you really should try not
to get pregnant for two to three months
and the details really depend upon your
particular situation and you should talk
with your doctor okay so let's then jump
from that to it kind of got handled it
feels a little mysterious but why it's
well managed but now let's jump to how
the immune system is involved in trying
to conceive and kind of what happens so
that we can address just the immunity
nature of trying to fight off of our
eros at the same time of trying to
support a healthy pregnancy how is the
immune system involved when you're
trying to conceive and growing a human
inside your body it's a lot of it it's
actually a mystery Alex but I think that
there is some evidence that pregnant
women number one when you're pregnant
a lot of resources in your body are
being taken up for the pregnancy you
know so you can imagine that if somebody
like maybe is a like some of their
health resources have been taken away
because they're rundown or whatever that
they might not fight off an infection as
well and that's probably part of it I'm
not sure that we have something more
precise than that to tell you like Zika
is really not in that category the Zika
issue is more that the virus replicates
in the placenta and then impacts the
child so we don't have
on this virus right right with the flu
with the flu it just appears that you
know pregnant pregnant women are more
susceptible to serious complications of
the flu so most people get the flu they
feel horrible horrible horrible for a
few days but then they get better but if
the people that get the flu and end up
in the hospital are people who are sick
and old and immuno compromised and
pregnant women so those you know we just
know and that's why there's such a
strong recommendation every single year
from American College of ob-gyn the
w-h-o the CDC ASRM for people that are
planning to get pregnant or pregnant to
get the flu shot because we really do
feel like you're high risk you do get
those things in first trimester there's
very few over-the-counter remedies
medicines you know things that we can
buy at CVS or Walgreens that can can
alleviate our symptoms - I mean isn't
that also true there are certain things
we have to avoid during first trimester
so um I don't know that that's really
true but those things
even though you can run out to the
drugstore and buy those things we don't
want you to buy those things or take
those things without talking to a doctor
right though you are feeling sick you
need to just you need to go get some
real medical advice you need to go and
get examined and tested and then the
doctor basically weighs the risks and
the benefits of over-the-counter and
prescription medications and will tell
you what's okay and what's not okay to
take because like we don't want you to
take tylenol for no reason but if you
have a high fever the risk of the high
fever is higher than the risk of Tylenol
so there in that particular case we
would probably give you tylenol but of
course it depends like what if you have
a liver issue then we probably wouldn't
give you Tylenol so it it's the don't
self-medicate
go and self-medicate actually speak to
your primary care doctor speak to your
OB speak to your fertility specialist if
you're still deciding the window of
being taken care of by a doctor Chen you
know or someone who is an REI that you
that your being taking it are doing this
don't just run out to the drugstore
don't ask dr. Google what to do right
you know doctor so what what is your
health system recommend even to health
care providers because we certainly also
don't want somebody who is suspected of
having coronavirus the whole 14-day
quarantine is really important we don't
want them running into it to us clinic
you know and staying in the sick waiting
room and then spreading the coronavirus
everywhere so with your health system
recommending to people they're
recommending everybody who is coming
from the high-risk places right now it's
Trina Iran Italy and Korea those those
countries are on red alert now right
orange alert is Japan yellow alert is
Hong Kong so those and it may change
tomorrow it may change so the big thing
is CDC gov put in the search term
coronavirus or flu or Zika virus
whatever you're looking for the CDC is
doing a phenomenal job of trying to get
the right information out very very
quickly and I've been watching this
they've been you know they've been
changing the alerts every day turns out
more so that there's been a couple of
reported cases that that they can't
trace to one of the high-risk areas and
I think that's where a lot of this fear
and panic come from and right so we also
know about this virus that it lives on
surfaces for a very long time my
understanding is it's it does it's not
clear that it lives on surfaces for a
very long time but that is why you
really need to wash your hands
frequently because right when you are
possibly touching possibly infected
surfaces and we don't know how long the
virus can live around and then you touch
your eye or you touch your nose or you
touch your mouth that's how you can
possibly inoculate yourself and that is
why hand
she is so important wearing a mask you
know unless you're you're taking care of
somebody who's actively coughing on you
right and has a fever wearing a mask is
really not protective you know like
their the CDC recommends try to stay six
feet away from people that are coughing
and people that are coughing or have a
fever really should be staying at home
or wearing a mask but this idea of going
you and I like going out and wearing a
mask it's not keep rising your hands and
to and to tell our patients you know and
we've been telling our patients you know
if you have a fever you should stay at
home like you know even if you've never
been to a high risk area sure you have
something that's you know and you
shouldn't be
infecting other people so here's
something though I think that we have to
address and that's medical tourism in
our field because the Chinese market is
virtually shut down right now for anyone
who was expecting to come to the u.s. to
do an egg donor cycle a surrogacy cycle
or an IVF cycle which you know I just
find devastating right to consider that
that someone is lying in wait because of
what they're dealing with with this
epidemic it's really devastating to
think about Italy now is facing the same
you know where where folks who need IVF
and PGD have to get out of Italy to do
it you know or something with their
surrogacy cycle you know I mean how long
do you think this might last and my well
you know the the the biology and I'm not
a virologist obviously but it does seem
like the biology of these coronaviruses
that we with they they seem to do really
well in cold temperatures so it does
seem like he makes a difference so like
you know boiling things and using
disinfectant and hot weather like when
the weather changes it does seem like a
lot of people believe that it's going to
get better than obviously we don't know
that for sure but in general
coronaviruses do seem to do really well
in in cooler temps no heat up the bar
so go ahead and douse your eggs with hot
sauce in other words like ginger tea I
mean how hot can you take it was savvy
enough on your salmon sushi yeah I don't
know if it's like spicy Thai think we're
talking temperature t we can't we can't
well exercise I mean we can increase our
core body temperature at least
temporarily does exercise there think
you know it's just like other viruses
like getting enough sleep eating your
vegetables taking our vitamins and
getting regular exercise are all you
know they're all good ideas for staying
healthy in general I think the same
applies to the virus you do you know if
you see somebody coughing stay away from
them tell tell people at work listen to
me I'm coffee I know that's [ __ ]
combination so we're the the these are
the just to help you this is the latest
just came out yesterday screening
screening for corona virus is high fever
upper or lower respiratory infection and
within 14 days travel to one of the high
risk areas or contact with somebody
who's been traveling to a high risk area
peep all people that are hospitalized
with a high fever and lower upper
respiratory infection will now be
screened for corona virus regardless of
travel precautions so the super severe
people in the hospital all of those
people now by CDC guidelines will have
to be screened for corona virus but if
you're not in the hospital
it really is related to where have you
been have you been to a high risk area
and again obviously doesn't China Iran
Italy and I'm forgetting one China Iran
Italy Korea those are an you mention its
Noel Japan and Hong Kong our contact on
that list as well so my last quick
question before we wrap it up that was
our alarm so we wouldn't go over today
since you and I are is historic it was
historically we go over is so there are
all these clinics though that cater to
those international
Asians so what should folks be asking
before they go into their clinic their
local clinic you know there's lots in
California who cater to the Chinese
population and in New York and you know
should be we don't want people to panic
again you know should they be calling up
the clinic and finding out you know have
you had any patients that have traveled
within the last 14 days from these
hotspot areas you know what are you
doing about it is there anything at this
point like how do people get here from
those countries they come through the
airport and everybody coming from those
areas actually is being pulled aside at
the at the level of our airports okay
they are you know are people quarantine
yeah they're up there they're being
pulled aside in screen okay so I feel I
feel like it's certainly reasonable for
people to call their clinics and say
what are you doing about this but I
don't think you have to I don't I feel
like it's it's it's not helpful to like
just you know stay at home and worry
about like oh you might have sure the
Eiger clinic with that I feel I feel
like that's probably going beyond what
you need to do going going into panic
mode rather than just self self-id
reassurance and you know just not them
bleep we don't want people to panic now
one thing I did want to ask and I
thought I had my last question this my
last question is there's no I talked
about the medications that are that are
manufactured in China not being able to
get out of China because they have you
know workers on lockdown you know people
are still whole cities that are being
quarantined does that affect the
fertility field at all do you know of
any medications that are manufactured in
China where we might see a shortage of
fertility medications related to a knife
like aware of right now okay but if we
do learn of that well we'll be the first
to let everybody know so certainly don't
want that to be an issue either if
somebody can't get there plummet or
metformin or you know any of the drugs
that are manufactured for hormone
stimulation itself or for trigger shots
etc so the key is is treat this like any
other flu season and virus don't treat
it as anything
scarier than that you know practice
logic and reason you know street smarts
don't you wear masks is not protecting
you anyway
while your hand washing alive you're on
army yep your nose and just check in
with the cdc.gov site a great way to
follow the CDC is actually through
social media they're very good at
putting out alerts through social media
and but this will conclude on I will
include the link below the heat map
exactly and there they're excellent for
all those kinds of things so before you
know before you travel anywhere there
they're very up-to-date on all of those
things and they are doing screening at
the airports so great company if
somebody fits the quarantine criteria
they're catching them at the airports
and you know like just it's that we
don't we really don't feel like the
risks are super high this blue we
actually feel like the risk for getting
the flu is higher so we do want people
to think about going going to them to
get the vaccine okay it does sound like
it well we're so grateful for all your
input on that and you have such a calm
presence and demeanor about it and I
think a lot of our patients are
concerned and just curious you know
passage of this is a consideration as
they're actively trying to conceive you
can always find us on the fertility
Answers app we had a beautiful release
today that we can match you directly to
providers in your area to solutions that
you need and even clinical trials and a
very visually compelling way on your app
platform it's available on iOS and
Android
so check out dr. Chen certainly inside
the platform and we'll see you next week
same time same place for our Monday
motivation with Alice and doctor ten
thanks Serena bye